Halloween is upon us so to celebrate I
thought I discussed the ending of one of
my favorite horror movies the witch
audiences tend to be completely
polarized on the film and there's
definitely a lot of mixed opinions on
what it represents throughout this video
I'll be discussing the ending of the
witch and giving my thoughts on exactly
what I think the film's ending
symbolizes there will be heavy spoilers
and I definitely recommend that you give
this movie a watch if you're yet to see
it with that out the way I'm definition
and I ruin the movie so you don't have
to by the end of the witch you may be
wondering why Ana has decided to join a
coven of witches and give her body to
Satan in order to fully understand this
we have to look at the character of Ana
from the start and decipher why she has
had such an evil turn Ana is the one
family member that seems to deeply
regret the banishment that is forced
upon them even from the film's opening
scene we can see the regret that takes
over her and this highlights how she may
wish to seek company amongst other
communities in the introduction Ana is
the last to leave the church and when
the family are forced to desert the
Commonwealth she looks back at the
settlement one last time almost begging
that they accept her this fear of no
longer being a part of a religious sect
and therefore no longer allowed into
heaven really drives the characters
motivations throughout the film
early on we witness and you're praying
and begging that Christ saves her soul
from hell she also pleased that she be
granted the mind state that her father
made the right choice in making the
family leave and it's here where Satan
sets his sights on her Ana is a young
virgin filled with doubt and cast out
from the flock which makes her the
perfect target for the commander of Hell
and the entire plot of the movie centers
around him slowly turning her Satan
knows that Aeneas secretly longs for the
Commonwealth and the luxuries that come
with it she recounts to her brother
about the wonderful glass work that was
present there and it's clear she still
longs to be part of a
immunity this makes her the perfect
target for temptation and is the reason
why she so easily manipulated she is a
weak lost young girl and this makes her
choice at the end even more
understandable by the final scene of the
film her entire family are dead so she's
left with very little opportunities but
on Deva starving to death or trying to
reach the Commonwealth on foot at the
Commonwealth she will most likely be
accused of becoming a witch as she tries
to explain her family's demise so this
isn't really an option on you to feel
shunned by God she prayed throughout the
film and still was left with her
family's betrayal and death her father
who was a devout man hated her and
framed her poisoning her family against
her to the point that her mother
attempted to murder her whilst Aniyah
was right to fight back she still
committed matricide witch in the 17th
century would have been viewed as
unforgivable especially in God's eyes
in the end with her mind state and God
being a polar opposite to how it was at
the beginning of the film it becomes
easy for her to turn for butter a pretty
dress and to live deliciously food is of
course a necessity and we already know
that Aniyah desired a higher standard of
living
hence the mention of the dress and
living to an enjoyable level Anna felt
unaccepted by both God and her family
they tried to be rid of her several
times during the movie and made her feel
massively unwelcome the society she is
from made her subservient and also
judged her because of her gender and age
juxtaposing this Satan seems to have
open arms for her and the promise of an
opportunity to rule alongside him this
would massively outweigh the negatives
that she's faced thus far in her past
life and would seem like the best way
forwards when Aniyah is stripped from
all the oppression the gravity of the
situation
lifts spiritually and physically and the
character is able to finally flow up
with all the other liberated souls
however it's not a completely happy
ending and viewers may wonder what
happened to the rest of her siblings
they have in fact been used to flame the
fire that we see at the end and Annie
will now have to do the same to other
families if she wishes to remain in the
good graces of her new guard so what are
your thoughts on the ending of the witch
did you take a different interpretation
from the film and is there anything I
missed that further backs of my theory
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of the ending
of Suspiria that too has a similar
aesthetic to this film and is definitely
worth watching if you want a good scare
this Halloween this is a channel for
people who are heavy into horror so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]